hey everyone it's Jonah here I'm back
most of you might know that I have been
away for seven weeks mostly in Malaysia
and also two weeks in Taiwan it has been
a lovely time spending it with my family
and friends
due to the constant travelling being in
different places all the time meeting
different people and also the constant
eating out well I have to be honest it
has affected my diet firstly I have put
on some weight but besides that I can
see and feel the difference for instance
I experienced break out feeling tired
lethargic lazy at times and also feeling
bloated due to the overeating and it is
not nice to be constipated so this is my
first week back and I am also cleaning
up my diet what I'm going to share with
you today is an example of my daily
meals in eating clean morning guys I'm
just waiting for my breakfast to cook
right now and I start my day by drinking
a huge glass of water and also a part of
green tea I tend to have my water prior
to my breakfast and this pot of green
tea together with my breakfast
throughout the day I will be able to
drink at least 2.5 to 3 liters of water
and also a combination of green tea so
remember to keep yourself hydrated from
the moment you are awake for breakfast
it's always something really simple and
quick one whole grain toast I've sliced
it into half because my toast is rather
thick I've topped one side up with one
whole egg and one egg white poached and
the other side I've spread it with a
little bit of jam I like to have my
complex carbs and protein in the morning
because in about an hour time I will be
heading to the gym and I like to keep my
breakfast rather light for the gym
trying to go for Jam without any added
sugar so that you will get the natural
sweetness from the fruits itself so this
is my breakfast quick and easy and I
tend to have this pretty much every day
I just got back from the gym I did kick
boxing today and so I'm going to
replenish my body with a huge glass of
green smoothie dudes do remember how to
make a healthy and delicious green
smoothie really simple only four
ingredients first choose your green
vegetable I've chosen kill second choose
your liquid or liquids
I've chosen soya milk and water third
choose your fruit or vegetable I've
chosen banana and fourth your add-ons
I've chosen goji berries for the extra
antioxidants and sweetness add all the
ingredients into your smoothie blender
and blend it up having green smoothie as
a post-workout meal is a great way to
replenish lost fluid from exercising and
the cups and protein will also help to
restore lost energy remember to have
your post-workout meal 30 to 60 minutes
after exercising because that's when
your body is most ready to absorb all
the good nutrients for lunch I'm having
baked salmon in foil with asparagus and
also a side of green soup I like to have
a good amount of protein in my lunch
because it will keep me satisfied for
much longer and to keep me going through
the day and also I like my lunch to be
bigger in portion because it's in the
middle of the day I like simple recipes
with minimal preparation time so to make
my baked salmon and asparagus in foil
the ingredients you'll need are 1 100
grams salmon 100 gram of asparagus
quante can of chopped tomatoes drained
half a teaspoon of olive oil 1 teaspoon
of dried mixed herbs one tablespoon of
lemon juice 1 clove of garlic crushed
quarter of an onion diced and salt and
pepper to taste the first step is to
preheat the oven to 200 degrees
Celsius or 400 degrees Fahrenheit in a
bowl combine chopped tomatoes onion
garlic lemon juice and mix herbs mix it
well then toss the asparagus with half a
teaspoon of olive oil arrange the
asparagus on the foil then salmon and
top it up with the mix ingredients and
season with salt and pepper seal the
packet and bake it in the oven for 25 to
30 minutes for this recipe you can
replace the salmon with any other fish
seafood chicken or any other meat to
make my creamy green soup you can get
the recipe from my eat soup and stay
sleep video it is a huge portion but
this lunch is under 300 calories so try
it out for my afternoon snack nothing
fancy just a simple bowl of crunchy
fruit salad with my favorite seasonal
fruits strawberries blueberries and
grapes and I've topped it up with a
handful of grated cashew nuts if I'm
going out I will pack this in a
container and bring it out with me it's
refreshing you're getting the healthy
fat from the nuts and also the natural
sweetness for the extra energy boost
towards the end of the day I like to
have something lighter which allows my
body to digest easily especially after
the long holiday abuse so dinner is
butter beans carrots and onion soup this
recipe was taken and adapted from my
three days detox plan video the
ingredients you'll need are 200 grams of
carrots chopped into cubes one whole
onion diced 2 cups of vegetable stock
half a can of butter beans washed and
drained 1 TSP of olive oil and 1 TSP of
fresh or dried parsley hits olive oil
over medium-high heat add onions and
lightly stir fried are you fragrant then
add the carrots and the vegetable stock
and bring to a boil allow the carrots to
cook for 15 to 20 minutes until very
tender don't forget to stir occasionally
then remove the pot from heat and purify
karates even with a hand blender or food
blender bring the pot back to a boil
under very low heat add the butter beans
and parsley allow all the ingredients to
simmer for another two to three minutes
and serve I love my hot chocolate and
sometimes before bedtime I will have a
glass of hot chocolate because it helps
me to sleep a better good night everyday
I will give myself between 100 to 150 of
calories allowance for any extra food
that I might consume for instance I
might drink a cup of coffee when I'm out
or I might snack on some extra food when
I am out I do not cut my calories every
day it can be very tiring and tedious
therefore your food choices is very
important aim to have more vegetables
which are naturally low in calories and
it will also keep you satisfied and to
have more liquid based food which will
help you to avoid overeating I
understand that everybody's schedule is
different you might work late night or
it might not be possible for you to have
six more meals that is fine have three
larger meals at the time it's not the
most important factor what is more
important is that you stick with in your
daily calorie needs and do not overeat
as long as you stick within what your
body needs you will lose the weight if
that is your goal or you will maintain
the weight this is just an example of
what I eat today
I do not eat the same food every day but
the foundation of eating clean is to eat
food in its purest form so reduce junk
food processed food salt and sugar
join me and clean up your diet all the
best for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys